Stephen Cohen is a contributing editor
at the nation he's retired professor of
Russian Studies at nyu in princeton he's
also the author of the fantastic book
war with russia from Putin and Ukraine
to trump and Russia gate
professor Cohen thanks so much for
coming on to me right so I just want to
be clear about this steel dossier and I
don't want to relitigate you know the
years that we spent talking about this
but now that the standard in Washington
is soliciting information from foreign
governments is an impeachable offense
the steel dossier which was the basis of
the Russia investigation was that
information in whole or in part from
foreign governments well by the way the
first time we met on your program was
two and a half years ago when the steel
dossier was published it was January 217
and we talked about it then and I said
to you then this is clearly something
conducted concocted probably by
intelligence agencies around the world
and that's what it's turned out to be
Steele's premise which got him attention
was that he got all this from sources
high in the Kremlin correct that's was
supposed to be Kremlin sources but the
story didn't make any sense because the
dossier said Putin wanted to elect Trump
so why then we asked ourselves with
Putin's own agents give steel dirt on
Trump to destroy his candidacy the whole
steel document made very little sense by
the way we now know that that steel was
more of a composer than a writer a lot
of people contributed to it including
the wife of a very high-ranking American
FBI agent Louise or she said she
research for steel so I assume that's
what it means it's pretty surprising
pretty stunning actually so you've
you've been in and around this world for
many decades have you seen anything like
this this appears to be in part an
intelligence operation aimed at a
sitting US president
it's a precedent for this historically
right so you've asked me to go someplace
we can't go at length coming down here I
ask myself have we ever had
a presidential scandal like this in
America no I can't think of one then
because I study the Soviet Union as a
profession I asked myself did the
Russian secret police the KGB run its
own operations against Soviet leaders
who pursued policies they didn't like
and the answer is yes particularly they
taught related policies yes now I
connect dots and feel free to tell me I
shouldn't connect these dots that it's a
crazy Russian esteem but all of this
Russia Gates stuff seems to have
originated
that's what Steele tells us with
intelligence agencies American and
foreign what we don't know is why and we
need to know this they set out to
destroy Trump as a candidate in 216 and
then as a president after all other
American presidents had pursued
cooperation with Russia what was it
about Trump that determined them to
destroy him that is that is that is the
question I have theories but I I don't
know if they're right professor thanks
so much for that for that perspective
always it's great to talk to you Thank
You senator